one thing that's really odd is that
japan is so protective over its like
characters and it's copyright and all
that stuff
but they're like yeah sure put put our
character on your [ __ ] detergent like
like what how does that how does that
make sense i don't understand this talk
about the levi's detergent yeah they're
like
that makes sense but i've seen that that
makes sense i've seen it with many
characters like i said yeah
i saw a demonstration it was bleach
right yeah there's not bleach it was
like bleach it was literally just like
uh it was like a tome boys game like
like uteno prince or something yeah
there's something along those lines yeah
why is this solid bleach what does this
have to do with it i don't understand
like like these are characters that you
that you would like your company lawyer
would kill if somebody mentioned them
with and showed an image on a youtube
video but like god forbid you know god
forbid someone does that but oh yeah you
want to put it on your your toilet paper
yeah go ahead yeah i don't get it it's
weird it's really strange yeah i mean
some of the strangest collaborations
i've seen are like from ava ava ava is
like weird ava is the one franchise
where i don't think they have limits
like like literally i think like every
product under the sun can work with some
kind has worked with some kind of ava
collaboration if the brand exists ava
has collaborated yeah i know
there isn't like yeah i've seen
everything from like food to glasses to
toilet paper with ava and i'm like
well i know what i'm buying
i do like
you could literally live out your entire
life just on [ __ ] even much like i
think the weirdest one i've seen is like
you can buy like an official unofficial
ava marriage certificate right so you
can you can have an ava themed wedding
with ava wedding rings and have your
marriage certificate printed out as an
official ava marriage certificate
collaboration to be fair
key studios gave me official uh clan
admiral certificates oh my god i wonder
i still have those i wonder why god
knows about getting married in flavor
like honey get my blog
honey get in the robot
we're getting married
yeah
you guys will soon find out that i'm
having an ava themed wedding
i'm rocking on with my plugs baby i'm
just like where where where are the ava
suits i want my ava suits man i want my
oversuits well i've got jojo suits like
the actual plugs just because joe likes
to like because because ava is for
children jojo is for men
[Laughter]
that's why maybe that's why they have
ava diapers and not
jojo's suits why do they don't have jojo
diapers
because
because jojo fans don't [ __ ] themselves
i was jojo fans are the type to wear
jojo
i think about it
jojo fans are the type of fans to [ __ ]
themselves and just leave it there and
deal with it later they'll [ __ ] and
they're jojo underwear show fans are the
type of
jojo fans are the type who would wear
like a 500 suit but also where the jojo
diapers so they don't have to take it
off to go to the toilet that's what th
that's the type of jojo for are you
taking a suit off when you go to the
toilet so you need to like [ __ ]
unbuckle it
sometimes the shit's powerful you know
you got to take the whole suit on
but don't worry you got the you got the
diapers underneath it so you don't even
have to worry
yeah it's it's so weird but uh like
i i feel like do you do you think
collaborations with like other with like
franchises outside of japan would do as
well in other countries no
i don't think again the only one i can
think of is like disney yeah we don't
give a [ __ ] if the thing like isn't
related i feel like
if like if mickey mouse is promoting
laundry detergent i'm like
okay
whatever yeah it doesn't make better
detergent but if popeye's on spinach
okay yeah we've got another thing oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what i mean
if it's related among us trash can
a squid game you know what i i would buy
it
that's pretty [ __ ] that's pretty
[ __ ] cool to be fair
would i buy a packet of frozen lasagna
if it had garfield on it probably
probably probably if it makes sense for
the character yeah way more likely to
buy it yeah also be very much much
judgmental about it yeah i'll buy it if
i'm not like paying out the ass for all
right like i'm not gonna buy [ __ ]
garfield lasagna if it costs twice as
much as the regular lasagna true you
know i buy just like see what it tastes
like
probably like lasagna to be honest
it's like oh this tastes like chris
pratt
i feel like that i feel like there
should be more collaborations though
because they you know you do get some
fun items every now and again and it
works because people [ __ ] talk about
it right that's true actually to be fair
the only like collaboration i'm thinking
of that could probably like work really
well overseas is maybe like minecraft
stuff that was just so much my question
yeah i mean there's already so much
minecraft yeah toys right so like why
would you not collaborate you know i
know what the best promotion i've seen
in japan is well i featured it one of my
videos
you know the goldfish uh little crisps
yeah with pokemon and they're in shapes
of pokemon okay pokemon collabs
never miss that's true in my opinion
like pokemon has done such a [ __ ]
good job where like
because all you have to do it when it
comes to like snacks or food or anything
just shape it like that they could like
enough they could make an official uh
pokemon ak-47 and it would probably look
sick like it would probably like work
they would probably
work i mean they put a [ __ ] plane in
pokemon why stop it like why don't why
stop there go to fighter jets you know
wmds what are we waiting for man
i want my pokemon panzer tank bro dude
call it call a nuke vault form and put
that [ __ ] red and white bro it makes its
canonical sense
[Laughter]
like you know you pokemon is so easy to
market that it literally works with
everything because you've got like
universal that's why pokemon arguably is
like one of the most successful
franchises in the world oh yeah which is
why i was shocked to find out that hello
kitty was also close nearby in terms of
success yeah because hello kitty's [ __ ]
if it's not marketed towards me it's
[ __ ]
how can you brand hello kitty the same
way you can as pokemon i don't
understand because girls like uh girls
like aloe key better kitty is massive
massive because girls like cute things
that's like me saying girls like to
menstruate of course they do why would
they do it so often you know
[Laughter]
i'm trying to like i'm trying to like
follow this mental gymnastics
that you just did like how did you
equate hello kitty to menstruation
because to me when you say girls like
hello kitty that just sounds like yeah
that sounds like that boomer dad who's
like of course girls like hello kitty
it's it's pink and it's got a kid yeah
but that's you but you relating that's
administration is saying that every time
a woman menstruates they're like yeah
well i'm saying that the comparison
wasn't the boomer would think about the
phone
an idiot boomer male would think the
same way right
i don't know about that would you
mention so
hello kitty tampons we found the new
collaboration
the match made in heaven right there
that's gonna happen when is that
happening
it's [ __ ] stupid i don't know what we
were talking about before this i can't
remember why you're so successful
i get it that it has an audience it's
not saying it doesn't have an audience
but like a worldwide juggernaut audience
i don't know
do you know what any singular person who
is a die-hard hello kitty fan yes
[ __ ] like most japanese women i know
but that's just japanese women like
pokemon pokemon is worldwide god forbid
there's only like five of them
i don't know anyone in the uk do you
know any people in australia yeah i know
some people who are like super into it
i know a lot of people who are like yeah
i know people who are like hardcore into
like anything sanrio
sanrio is different from because hello
kitty is like a juggernaut on its own
yeah but how kitty is scenery no i know
but the hello kitty franchise on its own
is like one of the biggest in the world
oh yeah and to me but that's because
hello kitty is such it has just become
like an icon it's that it's become so
big that it's independent of sanrio it's
an icon but at the same time it's like i
don't know anyone who's a big fan of
hello kitty okay okay why like
competitive pokemon which is universally
anywhere in the world you go people love
pokemon yeah why is pokemon so big
because it's [ __ ] amazing
wow great argument there it's [ __ ] i
could say the same thing about how cute
well what's what's amazing about it
because because pokemon has like
cornered every single goddamn market
like any kind of entertainment market
pokemon is in it hello kitty is not the
same it's like it's the mean we are not
we are not
the same it's like if you think about it
we may have a key map pokemon has its
hands in every single goddamn pie and it
pleases everyone hello kitty is in like
what just merchandise now because like
i don't know if i'm like what i mean
like that's what i'm saying is card
games uh games uh tv shows movies uh
literally [ __ ] anything yeah because
i like
i don't know if i've just haven't been
paying attention but it felt like
pokemon just got like a pokemon go like
a second wave within like the past few
years i don't know if i just wasn't
paying attention and maybe pokemon had
just uh
slowly become more and more popular but
like it see it feels like it was even
more popular now than it was when it
exploded when i was a kid it's a cycle
yeah people get bored of it because they
play it too much do they come back no i
i would argue as someone who's been with
her from start to finish this yeah just
constantly being like this it's just
going to be like that maybe but i mean
it feels like it feels like for the
adult generation it's gone like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah the generation
there's that nostalgia factor right yeah
yeah yeah because i mean yeah i mean
pokemon was
was the [ __ ] craze it was a it was a
franchise that [ __ ] exploded
onto the world became like a worldwide
sensation and then i felt like at least
living in the uk i felt like the hype
for pokemon kind of died down and it
kind of became like a nerd thing again
and now it's just kind of becoming
mainstream again and like you we have
like the new like [ __ ] pokemon card
phase now where these have now become
like expensive collectors item and it's
just i don't know it's it's i not like
it's not that i didn't expect it i just
i don't know if i missed something or if
something
amazing happened that i wasn't paying
attention i feel like it's because
pokemon in the past couple years
especially has really at least in japan
has like really started branching out
yeah with what it collaborates with
because i'm thinking back on it now like
back in the day like when we when
pokemon first came out we were kids
there wasn't really a lot of like
pokemon collaborations yeah there was
pokemon merch yeah but nothing to
collaborate with an already pre-existing
like you know brand right but now you
have like [ __ ] adidas and nike and
like all these like huge clothes and
that's right i just wouldn't put it in
the same level as hello kitty but hello
kitty's done collabs with things like
gucci as well i i know they have i know
i have but it's just not the same it's
like it's not it's not the same because
i don't like it we are not the same but
i just know i just straight out i just i
just think it's all the same well maybe
it just you haven't been in enough
places where hello kitty is popular yeah
because i feel like it's more popular i
think it's just because you haven't
associated yourself with any anyone
who's actually i don't i don't know the
numbers i'm like i'm like
not particularly like a mega fan of both